hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything
hunters and Nan and assorted chimera and
things and today we're going to be
taking a very subjective look at hunter
hunter by examining some of my personal
favorite characters and I have to say
that this was not an easy as a list to
make as I would thought because looking
back on it this series has so many
wonderful compelling figures and it's
amazing just how to gosh II can turn
even the most minor of characters into a
surprisingly well fleshed out existence
for the most part anyway I mean there
are definitely examples of characters
who fall quite flat and Hunter hunter
but that is a discussion for another day
this time around we're just here to
honor those that have had the most
impact on me personally and unlike my
other top 5 list there really is no
greater criteria to this discussion than
that so with that out of the way let's
begin welcome to my top 5 favorite
characters in Hunter hunter number 5
knuckle what a story this guy is so I
vividly remember saying the first moment
knuckle was introduced because he looked
like a character that I would
immediately just hate I mean he was loud
aggressive and had that typical juvenile
anime style going on I was convinced
that he would be a detriment to the
series especially during the Chimeran
talk which was stretching on and on and
on and on and it was like I know I have
to put up with this guy but oh how wrong
I was I really was caught off guard by
how quickly my opinion changed in
regards to knuckle and now I consider
him to be one of the most prolific
hearts and souls for the entirety of
Hunter hunter as a series knuckle stands
out in a selfish world like this because
he is incredibly empathetic and a bit of
a softie
which works beautifully in contrast to
his aggressive exterior aesthetics the
first thing that really got me onboard
with him was how he kept feeding all the
straight dogs and every night he just
acquire more and more and more of them
so as a dog person that had a big part
in the change of my opinion but on a
more serious scale knuckle was a member
of the Chimera ant extermination team
who had a very different approach to the
job than everyone else who were all more
or less there to kill a threat
whereas Knuckles goal was more to see
and understand these beings before
making a decision on what their eventual
fate should be which was Alya I very
much appreciate it in a not consumed by
death and revenge seeking naka was the
small ray of light and it even
culminated in him willingly giving up
the chance to defeat one of the King's
Royal Guard
by deactivating a PR speaking of a huge
part of why I love knuckle also
to do with his an inability a Kawara as
someone who despises maths with quite a
burning passion I am still somehow
captivated by the idea of applying
compound interest to the world of nirn
and it got used a great dramatic effect
in the Chimera ant arc against both gone
and you P plus APR is just so damn cute
how can you not love this and by
association how can you not love knuckle
number four Kroll oh-seok Rolo is one of
those characters who unlike knuckle I
immediately knew was probably about to
become one of my favorite characters as
soon as we met him admittedly mostly due
to his Schmidt core bad guy aesthetics
but he only went on to become so so much
more awesome from there
he's a very classically mysterious
figure like you can never quite tell
what mr. Corolla was thinking and that's
probably for the best because his mind
operates had an exceptionally quick pace
so it's generally more interesting to
view his actions and then be given a
retrospective explanation of why he did
the things that he did but a lot of what
allows krola to be captivating is his
specialist and an ability being bantered
secret which when performed properly
allows him to steal the nen powers of
others and in most media power thieves
or mimics always represent some of the
more fascinating characters perk Rolo is
on a whole different level he is a
collector a connoisseur of abilities if
you will and he doesn't just haphazardly
throw one of his toys into your face no
he thinks very carefully about how to
wield and combine separate abilities to
create impossibly powerful results and
nowhere was that better displayed than
in his battle against Hisoka in Heaven's
arena which while it did my head in to
read through the first time was a very
unique experience in the entire battle
manga sub-genre but even his go
Michigan's Eno and silver was very very
worthy of attention I mean the fact that
this man has the intellect and resources
to take on two of the world's most
accomplished assassins and actually hold
his own is nothing short of amazing
furthermore krola also isn't a standard
antagonist because it has been shown on
multiple occasions that he does indeed
have some sort of heart and cares
greatly for the other members of the
phantom troops so despite the fact the
crawler will kill mercilessly and even
order an entire genocide for the sake of
profit he does still have that third
dimension to him and this series is
generally at its most interesting when
he is involved number three
Isak netter oh now we have the chairman
himself and unlike the other two
characters we've examined so far when I
first encountered natural I had no
strong feelings one way or the other
during the hunter exam he seemed like a
classically quirky old man who was
inevitably going to be super-powerful
but he was just kind of there for me
however the Chimera ant Ock
went on to change absolutely everything
of course I now view netra was one of
the most surprisingly complex
individuals within Hunter hunter at face
value his desires are very simple fight
the ultimate strong opponent but his
quest to reach that point was anything
but it was filled with lots of acts of
great good and great evil that make
Metro a very problematic character if
you try to examine the series from any
perspective of morality but that is
exactly the sort of thing I love about
Hunter hunter I mean even at the end of
his life in the series natura left on
both a note of hope for Humanity but
also one of extreme terror proclaiming
humanity's great potential for both
evolution and malice with what looks to
be one of the most sinister Ren's we've
ever seen that managed to scare even
marijuana for the first and only time
during his entire forty day existence on
this planet and of course a massive part
of why I enjoy netter O so much is that
battle that was conducted beforehand
with marrow m and the use of the 100
type Guan Yin Bodhisattva this thing is
a visual feast so much so that the
series is going to have one hell of a
time trying to top it in future arcs if
toga she even decides to attempt that
but in the end natura proved to be one
hell of an incredible character and
someone whose legacy is still alive and
well in the arcs following his death I
mean hearing stuff about his history
traveling to the Dark Continent or his
desire for the association to stop his
son beyond only keeps adding to the
intrigue and respect that I have for
this figure a truly supreme presence but
still not quite my favorite character in
the series number two Hisoka moving out
to the Joker of the hunt hunt well done
I dunno I just can't help but love he
Sokka despite everything he is and what
he stands for I mean yes he is
admittedly an antagonistic creepy
magician who was turned on beyond all
belief by the prospect of combat with
strong opponents regardless of who said
opponents are even children but what he
soaker achieves despite that is
providing a profoundly menacing presence
throughout the entirety of the series
there is no antagonist who quite equals
what Hisoka brings to the table which is
the sense of terrifying
Aniki you never know what is going to
happen when he's around like is he going
to go on a brutal murderous rampage or
is he going to settle down for a lovely
game of dodgeball
it's all entirely up to the whims of
this creepy clown as a result of that
dynamic the cool thing about Hisoka is
that the audience of Hunter hunter have
experienced him in every main role the
series has to offer he's been a primary
antagonist he's also been a sort of
antihero Ally and he has even become a
straight-up protagonist on occasion
which also makes him very very hard to
predict narrative lis like for example
with a character like Rollo you always
have a solid understanding of what he
stands for and where he's going to end
up in the series but he Sokka just keeps
bouncing around I mean who knows by the
end of Hunter hunter he may end up
replacing gong Kilowog Korra pika and Li
reo as a proper protagonist and weirdly
enough that's not an idea that I mind at
all and in regards to combat on paper he
would seem pretty disappointing I mean
he has a mere one primary Honsou and
another sneaky utility technique but he
Sokka wields Bungie gum so masterfully
that he has learned to adapt it to
essentially any situation and it's
always amazing to see how he manages to
continually push this ability as well as
his study of Nan in general even going
so far as to become one of the great
individuals to invoke post-mortem men
and become more powerful than any of us
can imagine plus I really enjoy his
design and general demeanor I think he's
just a really well pumped out character
in manga history and very close to being
my favorite in all of Hunter hunter that
is if it were not for number one
kilowatt kilowatt is the greatest gift
that this series has to offer without
this young zoldak everything would fall
apart his friendship with gon is one of
the most beautiful and heartbreaking
depending on the situation explorations
of friendship I've ever seen in
storytelling across any medium and it's
such a far cry from what I thought this
assassin kid would end up being when he
was first introduced
but in the end kilowatt actually turned
out to trump every other protagonist in
terms of sheer heart with the exception
of maybe lay Oreo I guess but it's weird
because in a series like hunter hunter
you think that Gaughan was the one who
was supposed to carry that sort of
emotional weight but for most of hunter
hunter it's about killer supporting God
supporting his first and best friend in
the world and that also goes on to
extent his last role in the story but he
becomes focused on simply being a good
older brother for both Alaka and nanika
after of course he had gone through hell
and back to he'll gone and in terms of
Dan use killer
always astounding I love everything he
does as a transmuter focusing on
electricity and developing spectacles
like Godspeed in fact one of my favorite
kilowatt memories in the series is him
activating god speed and taking on you
pee in the Chimera ant arc it was just
so right as well as the moment where he
removed a Lemmy's needle from his head
and went on to thoroughly destroy Ramat
killer just gets all of these for normal
story beats and that really does make
him the greatest presence in the series
in my opinion I could not imagine hunter
hunt without him
and that's why kilowatt will always
remain by far my favorite character and
that pretty much does it for my top 5
favorite characters in Hunter hunter if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general and
please do consider donating to the New
World review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time and please do head over to my
discord server or a wide array of
shenanigan Airi takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your own favorite characters in the
series this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next time
why do you emphasize on only hunter
hunter and not other anime and manga
excellent question basically I began the
new world channel to be a sort of cover
all for any anime and manga that weren't
one-piece because I already have an
entire channel dedicated to one piece
and as part of that I decided that I
would cover hunter hunter and as time
went on a hunter hunter video started
getting pretty exponentially large views
so I made sure to keep those consistent
and that trend has only been growing
from there and I mean we're talking a
massive difference here like four months
ago if I posted a hunter hunter video it
was guaranteed to be getting like 20,000
views well if I covered literally
anything else it might get 5,000 if it
was lucky like a lot of my Death Note
video still Civet about that number but
just over a month ago now the views for
the hunter hunter stuff seriously
exploded so now we're talking anywhere
from 60,000 to a hundred thousand views
on average and some of them have even
gone far beyond that so what I'm doing
on the channel is basically a response
to what the large majority of my viewers
seem to want well so I can't deny that
when I'm thinking about what video to
make next something that seems like a
guaranteed hit is always going to be
more prominent in my mind than taking a
risk that could get as little as two
thousand views in total so sadly that's
the kind of state the channel is in at
the moment I mean I don't particularly
mind because I do love Hunter hunter but
I also understand that that's not why
this channel originally began so you
know I guess we'll just have to see how
things proceed from here